[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben wir sind am ende meiner
ramadan reihe angekommen und ich schieße
die reihe mit etwas zum frühstück ab und
zwar nicht zum zwang sondern zum aid
morgen zum zuckerfest morgen der trifft
man sich ja traditionell mit der familie
und frühstück zusammen für den
herzhaften krebs zeigt benötigen wir 450
milliliter milch 180 gramm mehl einen
gestrichenen teelöffel salz und 60 gramm
flüssige butter zuerst verwirren wir die
flüssigen zutaten miteinander das ist
einmal die milch die eier und die butter
[Musik]
anschließend kommt noch das mehl und das
bald hinzu und wird zu einem glatten
teig verrührt
[Musik]
dann aber immer noch die mail klümpchen
mit dem teig ich gehe dann immer mit
einem pürierstab nochmal drüber und dann
habt ihr noch ein paar minuten einen
richtig schönen glatten teig
anschließend sprang ich mein kind mika
mit etwas brennt spray ein und gebe da
circa eineinhalb kellen von meinem
cryptic und vor mir das schön rund da
jetzt nicht jeder so einen top lenker zu
hause hat könnt ihr das natürlich
selbstverständlich auch in einer
beschichteten pfanne auf dem herd machen
und das back tricks und ihr dann auch
durch ganz normal ist neutrales öl
ersetzen und so machen wir jetzt weiter
habe ich die komplette krebs verbraucht
[Musik]
dass sie jetzt noch benötigen sind acht
bis 16 scheiben käse eurer wahl ich habe
hier immer eine scheibe halbiert lege
das in die mitte meine klappe die seiten
zu uns wollte es dann zu einem rechteck
wer das ganze noch riesiger markt wir
sind einfach zwei scheiben an dieser
stelle da kann man variieren wie man
möchte
auch wenn man wie jetzt schon verzerren
könnte so sind die clips auf keinen fall
fertig der eigentliche geschmack und das
eigentlich leckere komplett denn wir
braten wie krebs noch mal in der pfanne
bei mittlerer stufe schön langsam damit
der käse auch in schmelz dann einmal
wenden und dann sind sie auch schon
fertig die cap de kann man total
variieren ihr könnt da noch fotos rein
machen wobei ich den vorher anbraten
würde ihr könnt das schafft käsereien
machen mit petersilie alles trotzdem
möchte damit jetzt noch das
überschüssige fett aufgesogen werden
kann gebe ich sie auf küchenpapier und
dann kann man sie am besten noch warm
verzehren hier habe ich noch einen
kleinen tipp für euch wenn da nichts
übrig bleiben sollten für den nächsten
tag dann könnte sie ohne zugabe von fett
auf einem kontakt grill noch mal warm
machen und ich bin schon ein bisschen
traurig denn doch was schon mit meiner
ramadan reihe
aber es geht natürlich regulär weiter
mit den rezepten ich hoffe sehr dass die
reihe euch gefallen hat ich wünsche
allen muslimischen zuschauern ein
gesegnetes zuckerfest und eine schöne
zeit und allen anderen zuschauern
wünsche ich ein ganz schönes wochenende
bis zum nächsten mal objektes kitchen
[Musik]